and more remarkable claims by dominic
cummings that boris johnson did know
about this party we all saw the uh email
invitation of course and what's more he
gave it the green light
yes this is a claim that was uh
first made in a column in the sunday
times yesterday by dominic lawson son of
a former uh chancellor exchequer nigel
lawson in which uh
mr uh mr lawson wrote that he was told
that it was raised with the prime
minister
and his dismissive response was to say
they were overreacting and to praise
martin reynolds as my loyal labrador
martin reynolds the man now being called
party marty who sent that now notorious
bring your own booze email invitation
now mr cummings was the first person to
raise publicly this may the 20th party
um in 2020 that was five days over the
after the photo was taken of mr
johnson mr reynolds and uh doc and
dominic cummings in the back garden
this uh may the 20th party is the one
that the prime minister described in
parliament last wednesday as a work
event he implicitly believed it was a
work event he said note the use of the
word implicitly but now we have yet
another blog
from mr cummings who was the prime
minister's closest aide now his sworn
enemy who seems hell-bent on bringing
him down now
in the original blog about ten days ago
mr cummings said he warned about the
blog about the party but was ignored
now he says in his latest blog post um
i said to the pm something like martin's
invited the building to a drinks party
this is what i'm talking about you've
got to grab the grip this mad house uh
he goes on to say
the pm waved it aside um i had told him
repeatedly uh that uh uh the the private
sector should be replaced has had other
comp competent officials who knew the
whole structure needed a huge upgrade
etc etc uh he's my guy i don't want your
um
you replacing him with your person and
he
mr cummings also says uh that there are
photos um and uh that uh that they are
likely to come out and just to recap on
the tweet he go he does say
um the events of may the 20th alone
never mind the string of other events
mean the pm lied to parliament about
parties not only me but other uh there
it is the bottom sentence there look not
only me but other eyewitnesses who
discussed this at the time would swear
under oath that this is what happened a
daily telegraph reported this morning
that
the prime minister has been interviewed
by sue gray the civil servant
carrying out an investigation
mr cummings no doubt would argue that
perhaps she ought to interview the pm
again following this latest allegation
but clearly
there are conflicting stories number 10
yesterday denied the dominic lawson
claim said it was not true
but mr lawson's claim is backed up by mr
cummings here
and he is accusing the prime minister of
lying to parliament well
that would be very very serious if he
had done that he would be his position
would be absolutely almost certainly
terminal then tory mps would turn
against him there's plenty of evidence
that mps and their constituents are
turning against him already listen to
this from the conservative mp steve
baker now he's a big lockdown cricket
critic he went to downing street today
to hand in a petition and this is what
he mr baker said about the reaction in
his constituency to the events of the
past few days do you expect the prime
minister to lead us into the next
election for boris johnson i think it's
in a situation as volatile as this it's
impossible to say and i regret that very
much i i would still prefer that boris
johnson were a roaring success but right
now listening to the public who remember
very well all the sacrifices they made
i think people may well be too angry to
forgive but it remains to be seen and
how much anger in your constituency how
powerful
absolutely furious
mr baker also said that the uh
proportion of uh constituents opposed to
the prime minister was sixty to one uh
so that uh uh is uh a fairly typical of
many pemp's post bags conservative mps
report that they've had hundreds and
hundreds of emails from the public but
this latest attack from dominic cummings
will pile pressure more pressure on the
prime minister this is the really
serious charge that he lied to public to
the parliament he was told about the
invitation he knew it was a drinks party
he lied to parliament says mr cummings
and uh
the events of uh the 20th of may alone
never mind the string of other events
mean the pm lied to parliament about
parties we shall wait to see if the pm
is and his uh his uh staff in number 10
are still saying uh that the claim that
he was warned personally about the
martin reynolds invitation not to to
call off the party
if he still insists that is untrue uh
but clearly uh there are some big big
questions tonight for the prime minister
answer we come back to this may the 20th
party uh which is one of the most
serious allegations uh which directly
involves the prime minister he wasn't
the the one the night before the um the
uh prince phillips funeral he wasn't
there that was a number 10 staff but
this one he is dragged right into the
row because he's been he's being accused
of being told by two people according to
mr cummings uh that this he should
cancel this party it shouldn't go ahead
and mr cummings is saying that uh he was
his advice was brushed aside and as i
say dominic lawson said
people were overreacting mr reynolds is
was my loyal labrador said mr
prime minister
meanwhile of course there's lots of
reports that mr reynolds is for the sack
uh when mr johnson has a clear out of
the number 10 staff he believes are to
blame for the what's been called a
drinking culture inside 10 downing
street and all those parties